[Music]
this morning we are hearing from a new
jersey teenager whose candid words about
her own mental health journey have
touched people around the world
sixteen-year-old dylan levitt lost her
father to suicide two years ago since
his death she has opened up about her
own mental health challenges online in
her blog we got this she channels her
sadness and grief into an opportunity to
reach others for our series note to self
levitt shares a letter to her future
self about her pain through
her path through pain and her dreams
through a bright future
[Music]
dear future dylan i think about you a
lot i wonder where life will take you
and if your past still haunts you
will you have that beautiful family you
wished for
or meet the man who would love every
part of you
even from the time you were young you
were a dreamer
you'd see yourself accepting an emmy
award for your latest screenplay did we
ever get to have that
come on baby do you ever allow yourself
to think about the little girl we used
to be
she was so kind and had a heart made of
gold
she loved working with her karate
students and there was nothing that
filled her heart with more joy than
watching them accomplish their goals
she never quite knew just how much our
life would change
later she'd go to the dojo after a
lonely sleepless night the tears would
have barely dried when she went inside
but she would go because she loved
teaching it brought her comfort and
peace
we needed that peace
dad died by suicide which is a trauma i
hope that you would have gotten over but
what a selfish wish
i left you with so many wounds and scars
i live with a lot of guilt for not
acting on the red flag that popped into
my mind
i constantly think about that rainy
tuesday
if only god had given me the chance to
stop him
does your mind still run away to such
agonizing thoughts
for a long time you spent your days
trying to keep your pain at bay and
countless nights with a scream still
lodged in your throat
you were so very angry you felt
abandoned by your hero
you used to feel lost
scared
and hopeless
do you still feel that way
you used to display a brave face on
instagram yet you still struggled
you miss dad with your entire being
you long to hear his laugh listen to his
inappropriate jokes
and sing in the car
country music was your special
connection
does kenny chesney's eye go back
still make you want to cry
[Music]
but as much as you suffered you
continued to live
that dream to be an author came true
you had a blog that was read all over
the world
you called it we got this because of a
phrase mom always used to say
it gave you courage and reminded you
that you were
you are capable of great measures
you never wanted to be vulnerable but
when you did you realized that it wasn't
a weakness but a strength
your post the time is now was the most
real
you had ever gotten you told the world
about the ocd and anxiety that nearly
destroyed you
you recognized the only way to get the
help you need is to be honest with
yourself and others
[Music]
and real people came to you for advice
how crazy was that
you were called an inspiration
when you realized there was an
opportunity to help yourself heal to
share your experience with others you
took it
that camp you attended they asked you to
speak at their gala to support others
you did it
you turned your grief into a survival
guide for others one day the girl behind
the wall would be free
you used to fear that you would never
make dead proud but i know you do
his personality was contagious and by
sharing stories about him you kept his
humor alive
you promised him that you would carry
him with you wherever you went
how many times has dad been by your side
at a job interview or a fancy event or
even one of those days that beat you to
your core
and you will always have mom and alexa
they are your everything
i love these photos of him hugging me
their unwavering support gave you
courage
as twins you and alexa have your
differences but you will always be your
person you can always be your authentic
self with her
with mom
she experienced a great deal of pain but
always managed to push through to make
sure her daughters were okay
i bet that leslie levitt is the most
loving grandmother
i want you to never forget how much you
are loved
never change who you are
you are a daydreaming
karate black belt country music lover
with great determination
always use that beautiful
curious imaginative brain to dream big
and remember
dad is with you every step of the way
[Music]
thank you dylan levitt for number one
for her courage for sharing her story in
such a powerful way she was dead she was
14 when her dad um
took his life only two years ago it's
very few i was going to say it's very
fresh very raw and you're so vulnerable
at that age and the fact that she can
share her story in such a powerful way
will certainly help others and i think a
tremendous act of empathy on behalf of
her as a young person to look at her
father as somebody who is in a
tremendous amount of pain himself for
this to have happened and then the
introspection required to understand
what she's going through make it public
and help others along the way it's
really powerful stuff yeah and going
through something when you allow the
world to understand what you're going
through you realize people identify with
that and we should thank molly maslow a
top-notch producer
who put that piece together that was
very difficult to do nice job now if you
or someone you know is experiencing a
mental health crisis you can call the
national suicide prevention lifeline at
1-800-273-8255 or text hello to
741-741 we'll be right back